so this is going to be a little more of
a flyover than a step-by-step freshman
lecture which was beautiful man so just
like Dan did although it said sequence
comparison he spent quite a bit of time
just talking about one sequence so I'm
going to do that too maybe and
almost everything i'm going to say works
for markov chains but that's complicated
just like dan let's talk about
page2 just a mean a pattern so we're
going to look for that p80 in this
sequence thinking as my advisor said
thinking probability so immediately I
come to something how we're going to
count the pattern we see and the general
distinction is are going to going to
count all the occurrences of p80 in that
sequence are all the non overlapping
occurrences I spend most of my time not
talking about non overlapping so I
thought I would bring it in right here
at the beginning let's take the pattern
to be listen let's be heads and tails
and so let's take that pattern and this
non overlapping counts
go along until you find the pattern and
then you start over again the last
letter your market and then you begin as
if you were beginning at the beginning
of the sequence and one of the objects
of interest is what's the difference
excuse me what's the average amount of
time between these non overlapping
occurrences race or someone when a soul
is in it it's like a mouse just take
this here
this guy overlaps itself of course so
there's different ways so you have h th
th in the text so may have occurred for
example the pattern could occur before
this
could have had the pattern occurring
here this being the end of the pattern
then you would have had to have two
heads and two tails where p is probably
advancement is perfect or this could
have been the first time you saw it here
and then you would had to fill in a PQ
or this would be the first guy you got
and there's a theorem in renewal theory
that these asymptotically these become
like 1 over the waiting time between the
occurrences so why was I doing this I
was doing this because this pattern
occurs with probability P cubed flirt
that's an equation any of us can solve
if you see it's got in it the over the
overlap information so you would solve
for new being equal to 1 i'll do it this
way square Q squared + PQ + 1 / should
expect the time until you get to next
the next occurrence of this to be 1 over
its probability this because you trim
those guys off you've made longer
spacings so if the P and Q or a half
sphere coins this guy occurs with
frequency 1 30 second but this makes
that this is wrong so this says if you
do this non overlapping counts you you
push the spacing farther apart so if
there were five
heads in a row another pattern so
there's no self overlap to this pattern
these guys had the same probability but
but this one occurs in clumps you'll get
this pattern and then with probably a
half you get an overlapping lon and then
another over on anyone and then a longer
space so so the so the even when you're
counting overlapping patterns this guy
has a much higher variance than this one
so as you compute do naive using
binomials to compute statistical
significance you yours a classical state
so I'm not going to talk for here on I'm
going to talk about allow overlapping
counts but I wanted to start there
okay so I'm going to go through a couple
of things down and talked about global
alignment local line that just to remind
you of what that is if you don't know
and then main topic is the statistical
distribution of these alignments cores
and I will show you a couple of very
cool what's all problems that a little
bit of somebody did
so a gold alignment which essentially
Dan talked about we've got two sequences
we want to relate each and every letter
an optimal way and here we're allowing
scores so it's not just 0 or 1 but
there's a score of pairs of letters in
the alphabet and for the letter those
dashes dan was putting in we're going to
subtract a penalty might be 0 but
subtracted so this is alignment just
like Dan talked about maximizing a score
alignment and there's this dynamic
programming algorithm which you
basically seeing without in it and then
there's local alignment so in this
problem we're interested in pieces of
the texts that have the highest
similarity score so here you're going to
have you know plus for stuff you like-
for stuff you don't and you're looking
for the two intervals that have the
highest score and there's a similar
algorithm at templesmith and I were
lucky enough to civil on to where you
essentially start the algorithm over in
the middle of the table it has a
negative score up to that point you just
put a zero in and and we said yesterday
the introduction talked about problem
formulation and in I think 1978 introns
were discovered nobody knew introns were
there and in bacteria that genes start
they go along they stop and of course
that was going to be true with
everything else and then Sanger
sequencing got going we discovered these
crazy introns that were breaking up
jeans and gentle and I certainly knew
that our previous algorithms were local
alignment would not work in these cases
but we had no idea of what the problem
was we've been given a properly stated
problem we've taken us about 30 minutes
to do it instead it took us two years so
biology keeps coming up with bizarre
things that make us work harder so
what's the statistics of sequence
matching ah there's there are some
results for a global alignment but there
it's very tough enough on say something
about that we have some useful results
local alignment has a very good strong
law of large numbers some good
distributional results and I should just
say that blast is a program looking for
local alignment incredibly more
efficient than the dynamic programming
algorithm of Smith and I it efficiently
finds local alignments and it gives eval
use your P values for what's found and
the statistics are probably more
important than the algorithm is this
these papers two of their papers have
been cited approximately 60,000 times
each so this is this is usually used
stuff this is where I think computer
science and statistics can take some
credit for doing something useful to
violence
so I talked about this before we'll come
back to statistical long matches but how
do we count the matches and if we set
three heads in a row we were interested
in there would be three runs of those
here and if we wanted to use the Poisson
distribution to approximate rare runs we
would get it wrong and what is properly
approximated by the Poisson distribution
are the number of clumps so a tail
followed by three heads the tail is
Richard II Clemson so you count the
number of clusters of h's that are at
least three more so you can't directly
apply this and this has to do of course
with the the overlaps that I so you
can't use the normal that you would get
out of your first course but there is a
variance calculation that has to do with
the self overlap and you get a central
in it these are shortcuts and in
multivariate word counts you you have a
set of words more than one and you want
multivariate normal approximation for
the number of times word one occurs up
to the number of times were damn occurs
and these overlaps that was talking
about you could talk about the overlap
between two different patterns but they
would they would influence one another
for the dependencies so there's a
variance covariance matrix that you get
from looking at the overlaps between and
among the set of words and you get kind
of a classical central this is for PhD
students here this was the thesis of Ron
Lindstrom from Simon tabare perfect PhD
thesis there was plenty of technical
stuff to do surely it was going to work
out and Ron never published the result
but it's quite well known and high-end
Wang is in the audience here did a
Stein's method for rates of
approximation of the convergence of the
stars it's a pretty pretty neat stuff
classical working so what about this
global alignment that I've been going
about so Dan's example was counting 14
identical matches 0 for everything else
swaddle in San cotton 1975 proved that
the expected number of matchings was a
constant times the length it pretty much
has to be right if you didn't do any
alignment you would get a linear growth
in lineman score because the either
letters would be identical or not n
times the probability theory and that
was 1975 many people have worked on this
no one can compute alpha even for the
example of a two letter alphabet and
equally likely layers no one knows now
if you didn't if you take an example I
gave you and you didn't do any alignment
it would be one half times in for the
for the expected number of guys if you
allow alignment to show you how powerful
alignment is
that you go from point 52.8 to you get a
point three to increase over point five
by allowing dynamic programming to give
you one of the optimal alignment so your
intuition about what's a good alignment
score needs to be tempered by simulation
okay this is called the longest comments
and there's something called or gotik
theory and there's a version of kink
Kingman sabbatic organic theorem which
in fact allows this this conclusion to
be made that if you take the alignment
score and you divide by N and take a
limit you will get a value it's just we
don't know what that is
but probably everybody's heard of large
deviations there's something on Zuma
Hampton which is the large da Vinci
result and what it allows us to do so
right so our expectation center of the
distribution is its constant times n and
we want to have more matching than would
happen random so you would look at your
random variables subtract the mean and
there there's this exponential bound
large deviations of e to the minus
constant times n which looks absolutely
great and I had to write some survey
paper for society so I did simulations
thinking that maybe I would learn that a
zoom acting really gave practical values
and the the upper bound of the p-values
were one vicarage the sequences were
just not long enough to allow this to
you know again while
so in that in that paper I gave some
plots and I said gee the variance seems
to be pretty much a straight line and it
was doing before due to michael steele
that there was an upper bound so many
times and that would bound the variance
and slotland sank off conjectured that
the variance was a little own end to the
two-thirds which you may know there's a
famous result about the longest
increasing subsequence of a random
permutation a very hard problem but the
the exact distribution is known and and
that's the variance they get so I don't
take up very smart guys but it may be
there were wrong
oh and I also should say that when these
results came out I think persi diaconis
even in print said that he was
optimistic about obtaining the full
distribution of the longest common
subsequence because here adhered is a
related problem with a solution there's
some work in the variance Direction
couple papers have shown this
proportional to n variance but they're
they're fairly contrived sequences the
one the first example they had you know
one symbol had extremely brought problem
solve probability for two symbols
they've increased this a little bit the
reason this is a hard problem is that
there are a huge number of optimal
alignments in this sort and you can't
get your hands on the statistical
character of them as a whole whereas
when we're talking about longest exact
matchings it's not then we can we can
get some but I would love to see this
established and I would love to see the
full treatment for longest common sense
this is probably not an important
problem biology but it's a really cool
so let's switch to local alignment and
we'll just do it enough going tossing
first some of their plus coins and
what's the length of the longest run of
heads ah and the story I want to tell
about this is the story of the Hungarian
schoolteacher so this guy I think taught
high school you would take out of it
we've got a class of this half of the
class would sit down and dream up 200
200 tosses of a fair coin and these
people over here would actually toss a
coin 200 times now this is clearly you
couldn't do this with students in our
high schools but but maybe and hungry
people would look at heart and shuffle
them together and this guy could just
glancing at the patterns correctly
classified a bomb and of course there
are many tests for random numbers right
but he was just boom bupa so what he was
doing was realizing that the kids who
were dreaming up coin tosses would would
not put enough head head head head
together so it's it's almost guaranteed
you'll have at least five and probably
six you can do it you can do the
calculation and check my hair so
anything I think maybe it was for if
they had four or more he said they
really tossed it and less they didn't
toss it and he got right almost every
time
I seem to have digressed in my tongue
yeah so here we are so
so here's a trick of intuition which if
there's one thing it could take away
from today maybe this this I I love this
so let's look at the expected number of
clumps of K heads beginning with the
tail and we'll forgive you forget the
index so we have in end places and our
tail and K heads together now the
longest one is not going to occur too
many times let's imagine it occurred
once so you set this equal to 1 and
solve for K you solve for K you will get
essentially log base 1 over P of the
length of the sequence and this will
shorten a couple of it so that's where
the numbers five and six come from a
friend of mine who teaches probability
and sweetened tells me I give that
heuristic to my students and they think
it's a proof well it's not a proof but
boy it's a good a good angle to guess so
you have you know essentially number of
places to start times the probability of
the pattern
let me test you
n squared random zeros and ones on
whatever biggest square with all one's
so how would you do that what what's the
analog I act I keep pushing this
apologize what's the analog of n times P
we had before and P to the K that was
essentially what's going on so how many
places can i start my square and it's N
squared and if it's k so there'd be p to
the s and you set this equal to one
so this this works in various various
settings when you're interested in the
biggest one of some kind so exact
matching p is the probability that the
guys are equal and we're interested in
the longest exact match with these
random guys and
while large numbers is that when you
divide the alignment score by this blog
1 over P of n you get to where of course
2 cups unlike dan I'm not going through
the proof of this it's a bit sullen find
easily and read now all biological
sequences are not created equally and
this next material came from Eve asking
Richard Raja what about 22 different
distributions how how strong is this
limit law and
what what resulted was that there was a
similar limit law and of course the
constant doesn't have to be to anymore
but is between one and two depending
depending on how far apart the
distributions and that's doesn't what I
expected but ah but improving this
Richard came up with the
characterization of definitions the
constant and the characterization of it
being too just like the sequences were
from the same out the same distribution
but they didn't have to be the same so
there's a characterization of one there
too and I wanted to to say that okay
maybe it's what you expect I guess
I need the example to go through this so
there's an example a eyes our heads and
tails have probably one half and the
bees are heads with probability theta
and tails with probably one minus theta
and the reason we cooked up the silly
example is that probability of two
letters are equal is one-half times
theta plus one half times one minus
theta which you'll see is one-half so
the base of the log and the limit law is
the same everywhere so we've got
something to talk about
and astonishingly this thing is to when
we fida goes from point 1 12.8 8.89 it
sticks it to
schools
so what we knew before we proved
anything was that at theta equal half it
was to login and that safe theta equals
zero they're either all heads or all
tails so you're looking for the longest
run of heads or tails so you get the one
login that was the first of all right by
making sense here that if if theta is if
beta is 0 then the sequence is all tails
the B sequences all tails so the longest
matching with the a is the longest run
of tales any tail is probably half so
that's why we knew that was so I
expected this to look like that's but
and this is very pencil pencil line of
being here so this really wants to be to
log in just it's very hard to scare it
off of that so these are very this is so
robust results is what I'm trying to say
and you can put in scoring the thing you
have to be a little bit careful this
example we're going to have no no
deletions at all analyze it and we have
to have the expected score between two
random letters be negative but there are
a pair of random letters that have
positive score so this is this is
forcing it to usually the local
alignment algorithm would usually be
zeros but rarely they'll be a run and
it'll get randomly something so whatever
it is to go again and the P changes from
being the problem they of coin tossing
to the solution at some so you know with
no avail to know whether the
distribution of city for a chin Stein
here and probably will again
well as dying was a genius but Mr
Justice Department said he wasn't clear
as writer I've ever seen but amazing and
he had a completely new approach to
central limit theorems and his student
Lewis Chen proved did a similar approach
to Poisson distributions as Lewis
chickens and this begins to get
challenging but the score the local
alignment score under good before you
know this would be our center and how so
what's probably exceeding the center by
sea and it's 1 minus the probability
that nothing does which is the
probability of 0 and the Poisson so this
is the parameter of the Poisson so it's
e to the minus that that's fishing for
this will saw an approximation for
locally and this this isn't proved for
all possible cases but that can
emphasize these e values and blast our
version of this result and I remember
hearing David Lipman say that he thought
that the statistics part of it the
ranking of what's found when people do
searches was probably the most important
part of their contribution
tens of thousands of citations
so in this local i'm at scheme we're
going to count will go on member to cal
plus one with the letters are equal or
going to subtract a positive number when
they're not equal and we'll subtract
delta when there's a space goes and of
course have the kingman limit lot that's
region right here so this is
proportional to alpha n story up here
we're looking for exact matches this one
the ocean is the logarithm of the
sequence length I'm assuming both
instances what about in between question
and what I expected was that there would
be linear growth in here 00 logarithmic
up here and there be some Hush in the
middle what turned out from a simulation
was that was log personal log up to a
line and write it up background
proportional n up to a zero thickness
the real genuine line
proportional to log in interesting sharp
phase transition between these results
and the line was defined yeah so the
line is simply finding where
where this limit the expectation / don't
think is 0 so of course where it's
positive you're going to have linear
growth what about what about showing a
logarithmic up here and it took rich and
I I think three years or something to do
this and fortunately the proof got much
simpler with the Asuma hefting you can
almost read the proof but
so much less obviously of course and
this is just we're just talking strong
off here we're not talking about will
sign approximation and so but my
conjecture is that lassan approximation
holds throughout this entire region and
while the full distribution for the
Kingman type result is probably not
important to biology this is truly
important for biology and help someday
somebody gets there but he's from it's
probably proving this is probably harder
let's go back to counting number of
words innocent ones and not just for you
this is a slide you see if we saw before
if we can't use it by ama directly but
we can mess it around and get
approximation by this is a small variate
thing so a little bit fits in with with
dance looking for fast calculations
this is we're going to come to I really
thought it was some kind of students
thing i have heard of but there are two
sequences same distribution on each one
of them and key piece of k is the
probability that kayla k random letters
match and the computational efficiency
here is that we're just going to count
up words we're going to look at the
statistics of the words of length K for
each sequence and compare those those
statistics so linear linear time and the
best sets linear something over to
multiply the number of times W occurs in
a by the number times W occurs and B and
sum over all possible words that's
really look like simple statistic
and mr.
so normally for alignment we don't allow
these matchings to cross but in this d2
thing
you know all possible matchings so just
looking at this if you can turn that sum
of n a and B to a sum of indicator
functions does the word starting a tie
and a sequence and the word starting at
a and the B sequence are those keywords
equal one if they are and zero if they
aren't so we're going to convert it into
something that looks like on a rainy
observe Brandon zeros
that's what this says match indicator
get Kate word matching if K of those
people you can compute the mean and the
variance and so on this so here we have
random variables which 1 & 0 if they're
independent you wouldn't you wouldn't
need any of us to do that so they were
independent there would be approximately
normal the dependence it's not to agree
and using Stein's method expected to get
a normal approximation I'm just going to
go through some of the mess high-end
language involved with this we we
started working on this and I surprise
so this is just cheers to me all these
bounds here we go so they're the piers
the boundary got out how good our
distribution was approximated by the
normal da-da-da-da-da looks great right
the square root of log and divided by
the square root of n da da da da da so
when alphas lesson sixth the air bound
goes to zero you have a normal
approximation so we've got our onward
size calibrated about right it's log
base 1 over
of an alpha between suit however
he's working with us on this came back
and said it's wrong there's something
different about the uniform distribution
the non universe distribution and I
stupid they said Roscoe check record but
go back here probably a three letters
matching divided by the probability of
two letters matching squared is more so
so there was a zero divided in that
bound that I kind of life in went
through so and excuse me that's of
course only true for the uniform
distribution that's where the uniform
came in so here's a simplest possible
example you could look at this we're
taking one letter word so there's none
of this overlap nonsense troubling us
one letter words to letter alphabet and
the you two would just be count the
number of zeros in one sequence times
the number of zeros and the other
sequence and this is X is number of
zeros and first of its n minus X is a
number ones so there's our d2 we can
calculate it we can compute the variance
and then suddenly something weird
happens
Verrett p equals Q it's a your formula
sure did it the variance is order N
squared + P is not equally cute the
variance is n cubed all my computer
science friends always always would
claim that you know it's all just
counting and you guys are just doing
frills putting P's and Q's on there but
this is really different what the heck
is going on so let's do what I tell my
freshman logistics do to subtract the
mean divided by the standard deviation
okay we do that we crank along here for
a while and you get three terms unless
he is is a half p equals Q these guys
have disappeared so what's going on is
that these two terms are dominating the
limit providing the normal approximation
and this is the limit the product of
normals these two terms dominate this
guy that's where the difference in
variance came from I see it I still
don't sort of have it in my soul but
that's the story so you would have a
normal limit and you would be checking
how well the statistics of the Y
sequence is doing against the Y sequence
how well the X sequence is doing and the
cross product terms are just in lower
order and disappeared so so when I when
p is not equal to q and this is not a
uniform distribution these guys dominate
may tell you very little about what you
want to know that it's are these
sequences related so we have various
ways of looking at this every
statistician does as I said subtract the
mean so if we subtract
that goes from the workouts and then
some those centered terms you get
somewhere and expand the original due to
into this form you can sort of see you
can sort of see more evidently now
what's going on when it's a uniform
distribution P wxw this all adds up to
the number of words which is a constant
so when it's uniform distribution these
guys disappear they're the ones that
making the cubic variants when when it's
not not uniformly distributed that's
what's going on and so what what we
that's it so here's doing it's
subtracting law these kinds of terms and
trying to make this work just a couple
of comments about Larry chef who was
basic character of passed away not so
long ago in 1964 discovered that x and y
independent means there are normals with
their variances and if you did x times y
divided by the square root of the sum of
the squares you got something normal
again so we like this because it's
sailfin or Milan you don't have to come
up with anything out of blue there you
go so we hope that would work and we
also use x times y and this is an
approximation there's a lot of work in
this direction it seems that you give a
tremendous amount up when you just do
these four letter word counts and that
you can learn anything from it is is
pretty pretty cool we're using this in
metagenomic data trying to use it to
associate viral sequences that are in
whole the whole meta-genome with with
the appropriate bacteria they're there
they're infecting and so on so there's
these are actually getting you a news
used upon so that's where I am hopefully
I give you a bit of an overview of this
area and a couple of simple unsolved
problem like Poisson approximation the
whole logarithmic region and the full
distribution of water common subsequence
this makes it to me the statistics and
algorithms are all intertwined with one
another and then relate it's related
what subject in life should I get this
but um for the state transition diagram
you drew when you have Delta and then
you and at the shop phase transition a
possible to be what are the values aah !
art of that curve do I know I can try to
remember I got we in the same you get so
some of this is ah
so obviously those two point you know
something about so I think this is a
can't remember it this is this is the
Delta and this is the new so this is the
insertion deletion penalty of this
mismatch penalty and this is no one and
in fact we know this whole line but what
happens on here and I think I think we
know this line two so you probably what
we know if I do wrinkles on it they
would probably know that and I'm not
sure I thought you to know that where
the corner isn't so it's not a lot and
working working on this problem and
Richard went on sabbatical and came back
with the proof these interactive
particle guys are very very strong and
and this block argument back from
sabbatical and showed me the block
argument it took a whole afternoon and
literally ma I had a headache this is
just and then we found the assume a
hefting results that we could prove the
phase transition so while I was in the
happening which useless for P values for
global alignment it was incredibly
useful for giving a result of this very
sharp
oh hey so for the LCS problem yeah the
iid distribution having no bounds so
with anything of the following form be
of any use and you say non-trivial I
don't know what you mean let's focus on
edit distance and small it is anything
known for smaller so I'm talking about
but you see to get them random the
sequences to be close to one another
you're fiddling with random right I mean
that's what that's what messenger these
guys did they take 101 sequence and then
the other one they make it very rare
make one at one of the letters very rare
that way they can get their hands on it
and I think it's kind of a kind of
question you're asking this so they have
got a couple of really really
interesting technical papers in that
direction I see because there are a
bunch of those newer results on and
bedding edit distance to Hamming
distance with low gravity snaps so you
can't you may be able to drive similar
results I mean people have been the
point 82 or whatever the number i put up
there is is there are some rigorous
upper and lower bounds but there's
nothing nobody nobody could compute it
is alpha equals got another
let alone the full distribution and that
the guys that I was just referring to
they say something I mean they realize
that the longest longest increasing
subsequence of a random permutation is
related some way and they talk about
just a good question it's good their
papers a good place to start yeah in the
embeddings for example there are there's
a gap between the permutations where
you're guaranteed that instantly appears
once and multiple times on that gap
bentleys a fundamental guy apparently
and some smart people have worked on
this problem i would love to see love to
see the answer but it ain't got to be me
but i would love to read your paper
okay Sol shrinks